hola angela es una entrega muy
importante recordemos que lo anunció el
presidente manuel macrón en junio pasado
que francia se iba a retirar de las tres
bases al norte de mali y se va a centrar
solamente la parte conocida como las
tres fronteras recordemos que francia
llegó a ese país en el año 2013 a
solicitud de las autoridades locales
para ayudar a combatir el terrorismo la
idea es pasar de cinco mil hombres en la
actualidad a 2.500 3.000 en el año
2023 esa es la idea de las autoridades
francesas recordemos que las autoridades
de transición de malí este país que en
el último año ha sufrido dos golpes de
estados acusaron a francia de
abandonarlos en pleno vuelo en su lucha
contra el yihadismo y contra el
terrorismo según los expertos en
realidad es una justificación de malí
para explicar el hecho de que han
recurrido a mercenarios rusos privados
de la empresa va a tener que sancionada
ayer de hecho por la unión europea para
combatir a los terroristas el viernes
pasado en una reunión con su homólogo
francés y el canciller ruso sérguei
lávrov dijo que la existencia
/ wagner esta empresa que es propiedad
además de un amigo de vladimir putin y
las autoridades de malí no tiene
fundamento